award season is finally here so what is
one top trending request in your office
right now the glow up so basically it's
just a little judge we put a little
injectable in the cheeks straighten the
nose a little fill the lips just a
little sharpen the jawline and enhance
the chin it's almost like having a
beauty filter but in real life the time
for injectable procedures is at least
seven days before the event and then you
know two weeks gives you a little time
if you need an adjustment now the big
money question literally how much does
this procedure cost it costs anywhere
from a thousand to upwards of six
thousand if you need a judge that
doesn't require a trip to the doctor's
office we teamed up with Dr guanchie and
rock skin care for her at home glow up
tip my go-to product for a non-invasive
targeted wrinkle treatment is Rock's new
Derm correction fill and treat serum
because it has retinol hydrating
hyaluronic acid and so Marin which
worked together to deliver fast results
this product works in a clinical study
conducted on 31 women 97 percent of
participants headlines visibly filled
almost instantly and reduced deep
wrinkles in just four weeks we all know
skin care can be expensive so is this
product going to break the bank no you
can get it at Walmart for under thirty
dollars
[Music]
thank you